in a type 1 civilization we'd
continuously be using energy it would be
as essential as oxygen
we would also start using natural
disasters to our advantage tsunamis
could be used to produce energy
and earthquakes could potentially be
used to terraform parts of the world
with us having complete control over our
planet's energy sources we could also
control the weather
if an area of the world were suffering
through a drought we could disperse rain
clouds over it and bring it back to life
Humanity could also say goodbye to
global warming as we'd be able to bring
the atmosphere back to carbon neutral
and control our planet's temperatures
casualties from natural disasters would
also be reduced as we'd be able to
predict when and where they might happen
[Music]